[Música]
bienvenidos a la entrevista de france 24
mi nombre es ángela gómez y la invitada
de hoy es michel jamis la primera mujer
embajadora de francia en colombia
posicionada en noviembre pasado y en el
inicio de una gestión que tiene un
enfoque por las mujeres embajadora
bienvenida france24
buenos dias angela gracias por la
entrevista es la primera vez que francia
delega una embajadora mujer para
colombia esto en un modo con enfoque de
género no debería ser nada particular
sin embargo en nuestras condiciones
actuales si tiene una importancia
histórica que sea usted una mujer la
representante que viene a hablarnos de
la visión francófona desde los años 1800
o cuando inició el vínculo entre ambos
países porque
bueno quisiera recordar que francia y
colombia tienen una relación diplomática
muy antigua empezó hace casi 130 años y
yo soy yo vengo después de 24
embajadores hombres así que soy la 25ª
embajadora y la primera mujer nos parece
que es importante mandar mujeres a todos
los lugares a todos los países para
expresar un mensaje de la diversidad
tenemos una diplomacia feminista y lo
que queremos mandar con mensaje a las
mujeres del mundo es que las mujeres
tienen su lugar en las sociedades
modernas que pueden aportar su
contribución no hay exclusividad y estoy
muy feliz de ser la primera mujer
embajadora en colombia un país que
conozco porque ella estuve hace años en
este país de joven diplomática también
es importante que yo pueda encarnar la
francofonía
un universo un mundo de 300 millones de
personas en 32 países así que vengo con
un equipaje largo bien lleno pero con
deseo de hacer muchas cosas con colombia
con muchísima historia por delante y
mucho por cambiar su premisa asumiendo
el cargo como embajadora en colombia es
tener una representación usted ya lo
dijo que sea feminista desde que frente
se piensa usted impulsar esa lucha en
este país
en primer lugar bueno tenemos una
relación fuerte con colombia en el campo
político económico cultural en todos
estos aspectos voy a inyectar el aspecto
se me vino la diplomacia femenina de
francia se basa en una estrategia
la política internacional diferencia
tiene que tomar en cuenta en cada sector
es el factor femenino que sea en materia
de pasta en materia de economía en
materia cultural hay que tomar en cuenta
la constitución de las mujeres y este
año además es muy particular porque
francia y méxico van a presidir un gran
foro mundial el foro generación igualdad
que se va a llevar a cabo en enero en
méxico en marzo web o en parís en julio
no sé si va a ser presencial o virtual
que va a celebrar los 25 años más uno
del foro internacional de las mujeres en
beijing hace casi 25 26 años donde se
lograron importantes avances para las
mujeres es el momento de hacer una
evaluación de la situación de consagrada
bases pero también de luchar contra los
retrocesos y de empujar más más cambios
así que voy a trabajar con colombia para
la preparación de este foro
especialmente alrededor del 8 de marzo
que viene pronto
vamos a trabajar con el gobierno con
unas mujeres para hacer eventos para
preparar esta ruta hacia el foro
generación igualdad y que se aplique
además en las relaciones de francia y de
colombia lamentablemente usted es un
ejemplo escaso si hablamos de paridad en
lo que son las legaciones diplomáticas
en el mundo las representantes mujeres
aunque son cada vez más pues están lejos
de alcanzar esa igualdad con los hombres
porque para usted este factor femenino
que usted quiere imprimirle a la
diplomacia con colombia es clave y tiene
que marcar una diferencia
usted tiene razón todavía no somos
mayoritarias incluso no su amigo
incluso en mi propio país no somos 50
por el 50 por ciento en otros países o
siete países sí es importante el
proyecto el modelo mostrar a las jóvenes
estudiantes diplomáticas que si es
posible llegar a estos cargos es posible
ser respetadas por hombres políticos
jefe de estado que tenemos somos
legítimas yo creo que estoy o son
mandado un mensaje de legitimidad en mi
función que pueda manejar los temas
políticos de seguridad económicos yo
trabajé en asuntos muy masculinos como
el del sector nuclear la no
proliferación yo creo que al mostrar
estos ejemplos vamos a desencadenar las
mentalidades y alentar a más mujeres
intentar entrar en la carrera
diplomática es difícil porque es un
oficio que genera muchas complicaciones
de la vida privada que es precisamente
en términos de disponibilidad de
movilidad
pero también es un oficio en el cual
podemos brindar una contribución
excepcional al problemas a los problemas
mundiales de sociedad y yo creo que nos
nos complace mucho ver los resultados de
nuestra acción yo creo que las mujeres
tienen competencias complementarias
ideas y que podemos realmente aportar
una contribución complementaria y ayudar
a que se resuelvan las las crisis los
conflictos y los y los bloqueos en
general somos muy interesados en
desbloquear las cosas y avanzar miré
algo muy importante de verlo a usted o
hoy empoderada de su cargo es
precisamente dejar de ver las tareas
como masculinas o femeninas y verlas más
por una gestión efectiva y sobre todo
que por ejemplo en su caso benefician a
la gente benefician a las poblaciones
usted trabajó lo estaba diciendo en el
tema de defensa y en las negociaciones
nucleares con irán esto fue una tarea yo
diría apoteósica en la que
hubo que romper barreras cómo fue esta
experiencia háblenos un poco de eso
bueno en primer lugar tuve que
no imponerme pero lo digo de demostrar
que yo tenía la capacidad de entender
este este expediente que era tan
complicado del punto de vista técnico
luego tuve que trabajar con muchos
hombres porque en estos campos sobre
todo hay diplomáticos masculinos sin
tener escrúpulos sin tener vergüenza y
entender el aspecto técnico pero si
funcionó bien y yo creo que las mujeres
tienen estafas facultad de conciliación
de flexibilidad que puede aportar
soluciones yo creo que a través de estas
competencias particulares pueden ser
aceptadas en estos foros
una vez que usted ha vivido esto no
tiene más escrúpulos no tiene más
límites hay que empujar los joyce digo
siempre que hay que empujarlos las
paredes
a empujar los límites y una vez que
están empujados bueno tiene más libertad
es una experiencia extraordinaria que
todo el mundo tendría que comprobarlo
pues qué gran responsabilidad de ser una
mujer con un cargo de poder en un mundo
en el que esos cargos no están
reservados para nosotras vamos a hablar
ahora más entrando en materia de
colombia en los años 80 usted ya realizó
trabajos vinculados con la diplomacia en
ese país después de eso su trabajo le ha
llevado a una decena de países entre
ellos están méxico guatemala y ahora 37
años después otra vez sucede es colombia
usted conoció un país muy diferente hace
años hoy llega a una colombia diferente
como cambió la vida y eso en términos de
su gestión pues que representa para
usted
si tienes razón yo empecé mi carrera en
colombia de primera secretaria de la
embajada muy muy joven y realmente
cuando regrese a colombia descubrió otro
país ni siquiera reconocí el barrio de
mi casa y todo había cambiado
la pareja
bueno estamos además después de un
acuerdo de paz que ha sido firmado hace
cuatro años que brindó una oportunidad
excepcional al país el país ganó mucho
peso económicamente es ahora vice
emergente miembro de la ocde
regionalmente colombia pesa mucho tiene
una responsabilidad regional es un país
estable
es muy importante con la crisis con
venezuela que colombia esté estable es
un país que tiene un peso de naciones
unidas- muy preocupado por los temas
globales medio ambiente de diversidad
deforestación así que el país que
encontré es realmente bueno ha crecido
ha cambiado y es un país para nosotros
uno de los principales socios en la
américa latina y sobre todo en américa
del sur económicamente políticamente
colombia es un país con el cual francia
tiene una relación privilegiada y me da
mucho gusto estar al frente de esta
bajada para desarrollar mis ideas mi
visa mi creatividad hay muchas cosas que
hacer aquí porque la gente es tan
emprendedora que realmente nos anima a
hacer muchísimas cosas sin límite
bien y conocemos que francia da su apoyo
al acuerdo de paz se realizado con la
guerrilla de las farc que conocemos la
posición del presidente manuel macro
y ahora entonces lo que le quiero
preguntar es cómo vendrá enfocada la
acción 9 francesa para el apoyo en los
años por venir de su gestión al acuerdo
de paz
francia apoya el proceso de paz porque
nos parece que ha sido un logro
extraordinario y por yo por haber vivido
en la colombia de antes del conflicto
armado
me dio cuenta de lo que representa este
acuerdo de paz que es un acuerdo
completamente bueno que abarca todos los
temas que que trata todos los aspectos
las raíces las causas estructurales es
un acuerdo muy importante yo creo es más
largo de los acuerdos de paz en el mundo
sabemos cuánto es difícil para
implementar todos estos temas
sabemos además que tienen 15 años para
complementar lo que conocemos las
preocupaciones de algunas una parte de
la sociedad pero consideramos que este
acuerdo es un tesoro que hay que
preservar e implementar de la unión
europea y nosotros estamos apoyando al
acuerdo políticamente económicamente en
francia la cooperación francesa
está trabajando con los territorios por
ejemplo hace 15 días se lanzó un
proyecto terra más en el departamento
del guaviare donde aportamos una
contribución para el desarrollo
sostenible elevar el nivel de vida de
los campesinos de los territorios
además yo creo que el acuerdo de paz le
da a colombia una responsabilidad
regional porque es factor de esta vida
regional no olvidemos que francia es un
país americano tenemos tres
departamentos en la región guayana
martinica y guadalupe nos interesa mucho
la estabilidad regional y a nivel
mundial creemos realmente que colombia
tiene este papel de enseñar al mundo
cómo se logró el acuerdo cómo se puede
implementar en el consejo de seguridad
es un tema que se está revisando cada
tres meses y eso le da a colombia un
papel realmente de ejemplar para dar tal
vez un modelo de acuerdo de paz a otros
países que no lo ha encontrado
embajadora muchísimas gracias por
entregar este premio de lo que serán
esos años de estadía aquí en colombia le
deseo mucho éxito en su gestión pues por
el bien de todos y gracias por estar en
france 24
muchas gracias angela y media gusto que
existe este programa ella soy tan
reservado y queda un espacio a las
mujeres
donde espero darle la bienvenida
próximamente gracias a ustedes por estar
con nosotros a nuestros televidentes
como siempre por hacer parte de la
entrevista y de nuestra programación
habitual sigan con nosotros
[Música]